يفوز رجب طيب اردوغان اخيرا على منافسه في
انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه كمال كريشدار
اوغلو بغالبيه زادت عن الخمسين في المئه
بقليل وتلك نتيجه تتشابه الى حد التماثل
مع نسب الحسم المتواضعه التي عاده ما
يحرزها المرشحون الفائزون في الديمقراطيات
الراسخه والعريقه بقدر ما تختلف الى حد
التناقض مع نسب التسعينات في المئه التي
غالبا ما يحصلها رؤساء الدول في الجوار
الاقليمي عامه والعربي خاصه من دون ان
يعرف لهم جفن لكن كلمه الفوز حتى وهي تعكس
نيل هذه الاكثريه البسيطه من اصوات
الناخبين لن تكون كافيه في نظر مؤيدي
اردوغان على الاقل للتعبير عن معنى تجديد
الثقه الشعبيه بالرجل الذي يقود تركيا منذ
ما يقارب ربع قرن وثمه بين هؤلاء من
يستخدمون الان كلمه النصر في وصف الحداثه
وسباباتهم تشير الى الخيبه التي مني بها
من جيش الحملات الاعلاميه الخارجيه
للتحريض عليه ونشر التحليلات التي تبشر
خصومه بحتميه هزيمته
استطرادا في النقطه ذاتها قد لا يختلف
انصار الرئيس التركي مع مناوئيه في تركيا
والشرق الاوسط كما في العالم كله على ان
المعركه الانتخابيه المنتهيه للتو لم تدر
رحاها بين اطراف المعادلات السياسيه
الداخليه فحسب بل شاركت فيها كذلك وان
بشكل غير مباشر اطراف خارجيه من تلك التي
من فكت يوما خلال العقدين الاخيرين عن
تاجيج الخلافات معه كما لم تنفك التها
الدعائيه عن رسم علامات الاستفهام المريبه
على لونه السياسي الاسلامي او ترويج وصفه
بالسلطان العثماني الجديد خير الناس من
ينفع الناس والمعروف ان الدعوات للتخلص من
اردوغان قامت وفق ما تفصح عنه صحافه
الامريكيه والاوروبيه الغربيه على حجه
تصويره زعيما تحركه نوازع الاستبداد وهي
حجه قال هو نفسه انها تهاوت امام مواقف
نقيضه لاسيما خلال ايام الاقتراع ثم تلقت
الضربه القاضيه حين تفوق على منافسيه
الثلاثه في الجوله الانتخابيه الاولى وحصد
اعلى نسبه من الاصوات لكن نصف نقطه مئويه
فقط حاله دونه والحسم فذهب الى خوض الجوله
الثانيه برحابه صدر واستعداد كامل لقبول
نتائج العمليه الديمقراطيه فوزا كانت او
خساره وان يكن ذلك هو مبتدا الجدل في رد
من يردون على اتهام الرئيس التركي
بالاستبداد فان علاقات التحالف التي
تقيمها دول الغرب مع زعماء مستبدين فعلا
في انحاء متفرقه من العالم لم تبقي لمزاعم
الحرص على ديمقراطيه تركيه ايام مطرح في
ايه قراءه للدوافع وراء تشنج المتشنجين من
تمديد الحقبه الاردوغانيه
خمسه اعوام اخرى بماذا اذا يمكن تفسير
محاولات اسقاط في الجواب يجادل انصار
الرئيس التركي بكلام يحكي سيره عمادها
السعي الى نهوض البلاد على نحو ينقض رؤى
الاستشراق ويجهد اطماع الهيمنه
[تصفيق]
بدا اردوغان حياته لعب كره قدم وتولى في
مستهل مسيرته السياسيه منصب عمده اسطنبول
ثم حملته صناديق الاقتراع بعدما اسس حزب
العداله والتنميه ذا التوجه الاسلامي
المعتدل الى حكم تركيا عقب 80 سنه من
علمتها على يد كمال اتاتورك استحدث منذ
بدايه حكمه تغييرات جذريه على خارطه مراكز
القوى داخل الدوله اقصى بموجبها جنرالات
الجيش عند دائره النقود السياسي ونجح
لاحقا في مواجهه مؤامرات بلغت ذروتها في
الانقلاب العسكري الفاشل عام 2016
اما خارجيا فلم تكف تركيا في عهده وان
تراجع الحاحها خلال السنوات القليله
الماضيه عن ترك ابواب الاتحاد الاوروبي
معتده بنهوض اقتصادي كبير وبتجربه
ديمقراطيه شفافه فضلا في حلف الناتو بينما
طرقت بيد اخرى ابواب العرب ومد جسورها نحو
الجوار الاقليمي واتجهت باضطراد نحو
التصالح مع تاريخها العثماني في التحليل
يقال ايضا ان اردوغان يطمح الى دور لتركيا
يتعدى دور دوله الدخول بين الامبراطوريه
هو يعرف ان بلاده لم تعد الرجل المريض
الذي يمكن للدول الكبرى ان تتقاسم تركته
ناهيك بانه لا يخفي تطلعاته الى نظام
علاقات اقليميه بعمق يمتد في فضاء سلطنه
العثمانيه وذاك هو بيت القصيد او ربما عش
الد